next question David Dhawan in Turkey or
Bonn in Hungary Putin in Russia Trump in
America is the 21st century shaping up
to be the century of illiberal
democracies the answer is of course yes
and we talked earlier in the week we've
observed that Donald Trump gravitates
towards authoritarian strongman types
right he seems to have trouble getting
along with people like Justin Trudeau
the Prime Minister of Canada a non
authoritarian bilingual French Canadian
not really anything that Trump sees is
inspirational apparently in somebody
like Justin Trudeau but he seems very
impressed with the Chinese President for
example changing election law so that he
could be President for life
he seems very taken by brutal North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un who he
described as incredibly funny smart a
great negotiator and just a good
all-around person or something like that
he likes some of what president air
Diwan from Turkey has done Putin I mean
listen what can we say about Putin if
you're Donald Trump at this point so I
believe that there are two factors here
that could make the 21st century the
year the century rather of the illiberal
democracy number one is the resurgence
of true far-right authoritarian
nationalism and we're seeing that happen
in many countries in Europe we've seen
that movement reinvigorated by Donald
Trump here in the United States it's
disgusting it's vile it is
counterproductive it is not the path
forward for Homo sapiens I don't know
how else to say it but the other element
to this is that Republicans have a very
authoritarian tendency right Republicans
partially there's two reasons and we
discussed this earlier in the week one
of the reasons Republicans aren't
actively punishing Trump for his
apologia of Kim jong-un or Vladimir
Putin or whoever else is that they're
just going to do whatever Trump says and
if Trump says it it goes but the other
reason is that the right has these
authoritarian tendencies and aside from
what used to be called the regressive
left until that term was completely
perverted and made useless aside from
the slightly sort of small enclaves of
authoritarianism on the left the right
is predominantly the source of
authoritarianism in the United States
they probably are realizing they also
like a lot of these illiberal strongmen
that we're seeing around the world so I
don't think it's any surprise when you
really get down to the nuts and bolts of
it maybe it's true too that the left
headed century right now is the 20th
century we saw this boy you know
uprising of liberal democracies across
the entire world ever since the world
wars and maybe people are not liking the
system that we have that would be sad
and and yeah now we're going to torn
through authoritarianism that's not very
good that would be depressing because I
think that what we saw during the 20th
century things like the burial and all
of that stuff my view was those were
merely the beginnings of a movement that
was going to go hopefully at some point
much further the idea that that was as
far as we're going to come or it is as
far as we're going to come or was the
furthest we came I don't know exactly
what the right grammatical phraseology
is but that now it's going to be a slide
to it towards authoritarianism that's
nightmarishly depressing but it's a very
very good question